[Music]
let's go out to appam madx Virginia and
talk to Keith hey brother
Keith how's it going what's up man I'm
doing great how about you I'm freezing
uh we had a nice little rainstorm last
night and um we got a half day of school
but it's it's kind of chilly right now
there you go we got the tail end of it
down here but nothing like you guys got
so glad yall are all right what's up
brother um I am a coach of two College
athletes um they're my sons I don't
coach them but I am also a offensive
line coach here in the area and these
guys have been playing football ever
since they could breathe um they're
they're your biological sons and they
play football too yes okay all right
great okay and I've coached them since
they were little little little and um
now they're being coached by someone
else
um awesome so yeah and so one one son
transferred from a university to a D1
school to a d D2 school and they're both
now playing in the same University which
is really really cool saves on gas um so
that's been awesome uh for the first
couple years they played quite a bit and
this year for some reason um they have
not played as much um my older son who's
a tight end hasn't played at all
practically and my other son had an
injury in the first game and just
couldn't get back on the field um for
for a lot of different reasons that I
knew about and some things I didn't the
question is how do I handle this
frustration this turned into anger um
over them not playing to the point where
I was unable to sleep um I was not angry
toward my wife or my daughter who are
still you know we're all together and
we're still live in the same house but
man I was just for the last six months a
pain in the butt and um especially
traveling up and watching them I know
this is kind of a different question no
it's I I was a coach I get it and I'm a
dad I get it um
yeah I'll just kind of cut to the chase
I
I I say for some reason I get it and
happens very organically but you have
tied your identity to their
performance and bro it's going to drown
you actually what's here's what's it's
going to do it's going to burn your
relationship with them it's going to
sever It ultimately and youall have had
this one bond this connection for so
long um it's going to sever it and it's
going to be a lifetime of trying to
repair it and you and I both know old
grizzled coaches whose kids don't want
to come
home yeah and you and I both know old
Grizzle coaches their knees don't work
they got that weird shoulder they always
got a dip in their mouth and their
grandkids are kind of awkward around
them you and I both know those dudes
right yes yes yeah so why is it this
isn't about your
boys because you know football in many
ways is a meritocracy that coach that
college coach he has to win to keep his
job so he's going to put the best
players on the
field yes and so for some reason your
boy's not
playing is making you feel less than why
is
that um I I played at a at a school here
locally and um was in all America
and was supposed to be drafted in the
third round so there were three teams
that are interested in me um and so when
the time
came uh to be recruited or they called
before the draft the majority of our
coaching staff said yes yes he will be a
great asset to your team well the head
coach said no well he was the most
experienced coach out of all of them he
was an NFL experienced guy and he was
trusted in the community and when he
said no they didn't draft me or give me
a free agent shot so at that point I
felt that no one stood up for me okay
can I challenge you for a second yes sir
you and I also know of
athletes who go to jail who get DWI who
under assault sexual assault uh uh
investigations who get drafted and
drafted and drafted and drafted and
drafted okay is there a
chance that it didn't work
out and instead of dealing with the
grief of I had this dream and it didn't
work out I had this picture of my life
of what it was going to look
like that has been easier to take that
whole dump
truck full of crap and pain and dumping
on one dude who yeah he may have tanked
you there's no question that's
happened no
question but is there a possibility that
it didn't work
out and a second more important
question is dude I can hear it in your
voice what is hanging on to that getting
you right
now well I think uh since the way I
looked at it and I know I I called or I
um asked this question a couple months
ago so there's some things that I've
done to kind of work through it and kind
of hold on you're avoiding you're
avoiding my question coach what like is
that
possible
that the story you've told yourself you
weren't as good as you thought you
were oh no no no I this is going to
sound really arrogant but I was good
enough to play I find that hard to
believe because those dudes have to win
to make money and if you were the best
guy they would have figured it out
because they figure it out for drug
addicts and for uh former people who
committed assault they figure it
out um I mean that could have been a
possibility I
I mean I've I've just had friends who
played in the NFL at that particular
time that agreed with me and the other
coaches of why it didn't happen
Okay I mean I just the fact of it is is
there were too many people that were
telling me that I should be playing okay
but do you realize the step between and
I'm saying this with a smile on my face
if you were here I'd be I'd be ribbing
you but there's a very Uncle Rico aspect
to this
right because there's that waking up and
it should have been it should have been
it should have been it could have been
and your whole life is passing you by
like a
train and then you try to relive it with
your
boys yes I totally 100% agree with that
as far as passing by different
opportunities getting my degree late um
and then now just starting to do the
things that I think God has for me to do
and it's become really really awesome
with the things that he's allowed me to
do right now so a lot of it has kind of
moved forward like I said I put a lot of
things that you had said a couple couple
months ago when I asked this question
and read the book and did a lot of cool
things and start to realizing some
things about myself maybe not the
question that you asked the first time
but that could be definitely a reality
but the other stuff I think I'm starting
to move forward through that stuff
that's awesome that I mean I'm I'm I'm
super proud of you super proud of you so
tell me about your your anger with your
boys are you mad at them are you mad at
the coaches are you mad at the universe
who are you mad
at I'm mad at the coaches the boys I
love dearly and we've sat and talked
about this in depth and I've explained
to them that this is not about them this
is about me and that I need to accept
and love and enjoy them no matter what
they do and if they stand they stand if
they play they play but I have to enjoy
them and love them regardless and I
think that has done really well in the
last several months but man they just
knew that I was not happy yeah yeah and
then you see that they start trying to
get on the field or cut corners or not
tell the trainer just how bad they're
hurt or whatever not because they have
this innate lunacy to win and you and I
have both been around athletes that are
like that dude's different than me I
remember being around a fighter during
my training days and one guy went pro
and I was like yeah that guy was that
guy was very different than me right and
you you you know those guys but they
start oh go ahead they start trying to
get on the field so that you'll chill
out yeah
right yeah they tried there's this
particular situation where T should have
run on the field and he didn't and I was
like what are you doing
go so um but I get really anxious and
I'm looking forward to seeing how I
handle this and move through it with
different techniques that I've tried so
far they have one more year to
play um so I'm excited to see how this
kind of looks hey I'm GNA challenge you
you ready for my challenge yes sir all
right here's challenge number
one I want you to go to the games and I
want you to not wear the
Jersey here's why because I'm afraid
that you are cheering in that you want
your boys to do well and everyone in the
audience is going to look at in the in
the stands are going to look at you
that's your that's my
boy yeah right 100% right and it's not
it's not about you it's about their life
and one of those boys at some Point's
going to come to you and say Dad I never
really wanted to play he won't fully
mean that but it will come out if it
hasn't already yeah and I also want you
to take an honest inventory because as
as you've told me your story as you've
told me their story it all hinges on
this one guy who just screwed
us and I've just been around long enough
that does happen dude it does happen
but there's a lot of miserable people
whether it's a politician whether it's
an exwife whether it's a coach or a
teacher or a professor or whatever if it
wasn't for this one person or this one
situation and I always want to say dude
what are you gonna do
next yeah and the more you hang on to
that past
Injustice in the present the more you
choose I'm going to make right now suck
and what a weird thing to right and you
tell you've told your players for years
you got to shake off that last play
Let's get back in there
yeah and what I want to tell you is yeah
I was I was good enough to play I was
and I didn't it didn't work out for me
cool right yeah yeah no that's that's I
my kids when I coach them what other I
know hey trust me dude I see a counselor
myself CU it's hard it's easier to tell
other people and same with your boys
same with your
boys I want you to ask yourself this
hard question too how much of the
coaching and the football and
the relationship proxy if you will I can
be around my boys I'm gonna be their
coach I'm gonna be their this I'm G be
their this
um I often find dads myself included is
that's an easy I know how to do that
thing so I'm going to do that thing
really
well cuz I don't know how to do the
other
thing which is to sit and read a
book which is to be I don't know how to
hug you when you got hurt but I know my
coach said just shake it off and so I
just start repeating
stuff and my guess is I don't want to
say that the time's been wasted it's
been amazing your boys have gotten a
dream they've gotten to walk alongside
their dad and cheer and be heartbroken
you've probably had some conversations
with him when the Coach Line crossed
over the dad line and you'd like to have
that stuff back hopefully you've
apologized as a as a true man to them um
but there's going to come a time when
they just want their dad do you love me
for me
man do you love me for me and maybe
that's the exercise to write each one of
them a letter and to say I've been your
coach for 21
years I need you to know I see the man
you've
become I see the way you treat your mom
I see the the way you treat your sisters
I see the way you tip well at some
crummy restaurant in the middle of the
night all the football stuff goes away
dude but I see the boys becoming men in
front of my very eyes I want you to know
that I I I almost can't breathe I'm so
proud of
you yeah that's good I have started to
read a book though you're saying that
but I've been starting to read books and
relax and take myself away from stuff
well that I've started to do that good
good good but hey I want you to be a
real gangster I want you to write that
letter and then I want you to get each
boy and read it to him yeah look him in
the eye and read it to him wait wait
wait wait you want me to write it and
then read it to him not send it to him
oh yeah in person oh that's yeah that's
cool I just didn't know if you want me
to send them the letter nope I want you
to read it to them okay cool all right
yeah cool I can't wait till you sit down
to do it here's the deal here's the deal
I also want you to write I want you to
write young Keith a letter
the Keith the night before he finds out
that his head coach didn't recommend him
for whatever
reason and I want you to write him a
letter and talk about the disappointment
and you had these dreams and you were
going to be on the field and all
that okay and then I want you to tell
them you think that you this is going to
be the way that life has to work out for
you and it's not going to work out that
way but here's how freaking amazing it's
turned out and then I want you to start
writing about your
wife and right about that extraordinary
daughter and write about those boys who
have come in and out of your life as a
coach and you have been the father for
them they did not have cuz their old man
left and yep you could have played as a
lineman two or three years and you'd
have no ankle mobility and no knee
mobility and one workable
shoulder that's all true and you would
have made some money not anything like
your the other guys behind you that are
getting their name in the paper but you
would have made some
money and instead you've been a part of
transforming family trees for two two
decades I want you to write a letter to
your young son that because I need Keith
in the present to believe that because
everything you're doing right now is
still waiting for this NFL thing to
happen it didn't happen with you so it's
going to happen with your boys didn't
happen with your boys it's going to
happen with my
grandkids put that whole damn story to
bed
dude because that wasn't going to be
what made Keith
Keith the story that was in store for
Keith that Keith was writing with his
life all the way was I'm going to sit
with young men and I'm going to teach
them to get more out of themselves than
they ever dream possible I'm going to
teach them how to show up and do really
hard things that they don't want to I'm
going to teach them how to dig down deep
work as a team all those things that you
get from sports that I love so
much and then you you are going to
consciously transform your relationship
with your boys to one where they have to
sing and dance for
you to one where dude I just get to bask
in their glow so I want you to go to
games and not wear the shirt I want you
not I don't want them hearing you
screaming I want them look up and you
just pump a fist and you go that's my
boy right there I love
you and I want you to send him a text
after the game I saw you didn't get in
the game one time and I saw you cheering
your butt off your teammates and that is
amazing you played your part today
not your coach sucks I'm coming after
your coach no I got to do that
crap because some kids are going to
start some kids aren't even going to
make the team and some kids aren't going
to college and some kids aren't going to
make six figures and they're still our
kids we still love them we still
celebrate them cheer for
them hey Keith I'm freaking proud of you
dude I'm proud of
you you didn't fail in my
eyes I'm kind of glad you didn't make
the NFL Uncle Rico I'm kind of glad
so I'm glad that you were placed in the
lives of all those young
men you planted seeds to trees of which
you will never eat their fruit that's
amazing now go transform it with your
own boys call anytime brother
proudy